Speaker 1: The next story relates to incineration.
So let me reset a little bit.
We talked last week about this report that
Trump White House staffers regularly had to
tape back together things that Donald Trump
would rip up.
We now have more news about this Trump White
House.
White House staffers frequently put important
documents into burn bags and sent them to
the Pentagon to be incinerated.
So you've got conflicting teams.
You've got one team that understands Presidential
Records Act and preservation of records.
When Trump ripped stuff up and tosses it,
they run in and tape it back together.
I mean, it's like, you know, I'm reminded
of the movie, a beautiful mind.
Some of you will get that reference.
And then at the same time, you've got another
team that is collecting records and sending
them to be incinerated.
Trump era White House staffers frequently
put documents in burn bags.
Regular burn runs would see these bags taken
to the Pentagon for incineration.
This is, per The Washington Post.
It was up to the staffers to decide which
documents to preserve and which to destroy.
It has been widely reported that Trump had
a penchant for tearing apart presidential
documents.
But details have emerged about how his aides
disposed of potentially important papers burn
bags, resemble paper grocery bags and are
widely available at the White House.
Organizations dealing with top secret info,
like the CIA and NSA, often use them because
destruction via burn bags is considered superior
to shredding.
That's true.
You can sometimes tape together stuff that's
been shredded, shredded you Typekit.
You want to use a cross-cut shredder instead
of the one that just generates strips.
But it's crazy what the kids these days can
do.
So you burn it.
Of course, it appears that it was done with
documents that are supposed to be preserved.
This was a disaster.
It was almost a comical fiasco.
The comical element being Trump eating notes.
And I told you about this last week.
Back in 2018, it was reported by Newsweek.
Trump ate a document after Cohen meeting,
according to former White House aide Omarosa
Manigault Newman.
She said she walked in on Trump eating paper
after a meeting with lawyer Michael Cohen.
In what she believed was an effort to destroy
sensitive information, I saw him put a note
in his mouth since Trump was.
Speaker 2: What is this
Speaker 1: story so funny?
Even though it's so insane since Trump was
ever the germophobe, I was shocked.
He appeared to be chewing and swallowing the
paper.
It must have been something
Speaker 2: very, very
Speaker 1: sensitive.
It is genuinely insane that the biggest issue
of the 2016 election that Trump made about
Hillary was document retention policies, and
this was what Donald Trump was doing his entire
presidency.
And they still have it in for Hillary.
Understand that, you know, we covered Trump's
rally about nine days ago in Conroe, Texas.
At that rally, he talked about Hillary Clinton
and the crowd starts chanting, Lock her up,
understand that the origins of lock her up
are over.
Hillary's document and email retention concerns
that Donald Trump made issue number one during
the 2016 election.
They now know or they could know Trump was
eating documents.
Trump was ripping up documents.
Trump was burning documents.
Trump took documents home to Mar a Lago, and
they still chant, Lock her up about Hillary,
who has never even been charged.
Never mind convicted of anything related to
that.
And his supporters will applaud.
They'll applaud, lock her up, and they'll
applaud Trump's illegal activities, where
he says, Well, listen, we had to.
We were just trying to take the election back
from the guy who stole it or whatever.
They cheer the corruption and chant, lock
her up.
Even though Trump did far worse when it came
to records and retention of documents and
handling proper handling of classified and
secret information, they still chant Lock
her up.
It's it is a backwards world that we are living
in my friends and the idea that someday these
folks will have a realization like Imagine
Trump runs in 2024.
And we bring up whoever is the Democratic
nominee, I mean, whoever just brings up, hey,
listen, don't get scammed again by this con
man.
In 2016, he told you Hillary was the concern
when it came to records and Trump eight documents,
ripped documents, threw him out and had them
burned.
He is the con man.
He was the problem.
Don't fall for it again.
It's not going to work with these people.
They will fall for whatever the 2024 talking
point is as willingly and as readily and as
quickly as they fell for it in 2016.
And that's why the concept of Trump 2024 is
so scary.